[Applause]
you're a Disney princess yeah that's
pretty cool at first I thought it was
just kind of like a joke that there was
but they were I thought they were making
a joke online but they were actually
very serious about it and they've
they've demanded that I become a Disney
princess and I will happily take that
that label as long as I get free Disney
toys what did it mean for you in terms
of like representation of young girls
watching your character on screen and
seeing them seeing themselves it meant a
lot because there was such a lack of it
and now that we have more characters
such as Sheree you know you have Meg
from wrinkle in time you have so many
characters that are emerging to
represent young girls of not only just
my color you know my my ethnicity or you
know black girls you know but different
girls of all races races and ethnicities
and shades and body types
yeah I mean so it's like it's a big
moment where we can all be proud and the
boys can be proud to you the boys can
you know find Sheree cool and you know
celebrate that and like Panther you know
they're holding on to that character say
yeah altogether it's been it's been
really cool and you're right Marvel has
made so many strides in the last few
years with a lot of females coming for
ya what would you say to like an
all-female I think just do it we've been
talking about it and I thank you for
going into phase you know the next phase
of Marvel the next ten years of Marvel
you've got a complete take that off the
list you know an all-female Marvel
Cinematic you know experience yeah I'm
down for that
I mean we really got to see sure you
kick ass in Black Panther but I'm
wondering if there is a sequel I'm
assuming there will be what's something
you would like to see Sheree do man sure
you can do anything I would like to see
her kind of been
to route a little bit more out of what
kinda a little bit more and help
different you know going different
missions around the world and hopefully
she can go in those missions with her
brother I like her I like to see her
have a bit more responsibility in the
land as well she is a princess and I
think in the first film she's kind of
like you know yeah my princess bomb in
the lab but for her to have a bit more
responsibility of having a say in what
happens in the land as well and what
what goes on that would be cool can show
a little bit more of maturity for her so
that'll be cool
[Applause]